well thank you to the Elliott Bay
bookstore for bringing me here I'm
delighted to be here thank you everybody
for coming I hope that you'll find my
presentation interesting I hope to
stimulate your thinking and I look
forward also for your comments and
feedback as well today as you may know
oil has reached a new high it's reaching
a new high every day so it's not hard
for me to say that and I think this is a
harbinger of things to come because I
think energy scarcity is going to be a
constant in our world now my book is on
one level it's about I think the
centrality of energy in our life but
it's also about a changing political
landscape I believe that we're
transitioning from one world to another
from a world a world system in which
military power was the highest criterion
for power in the world to new
international order I call it a new
international energy order in which
possession of energy will be the
defining characteristic of what
constitutes power as energy becomes more
scarce those few countries and they're
really very few in the world that
possess an abundance of energy and
enough energy to export to other
countries energy surplus countries will
be at the pinnacle of power and those
handful of countries and well those
handful of countries that possess an
abundance will be at the pinnacle of
power the rest of us like the United
States and China that are energy
deficient countries and must rely on
those few energy surplus countries will
be increasingly weak in the
international system will see our wealth
dribble away and payments to those few
fortunate countries with a surplus and
our political position will become
increasingly weak that is the essence of
the argument that I bring in my
and I also use this argument to make
some suggestions about how we as a
country might respond to that so with
that introduction let me talk more about
the nature of the transition we're going
through and it's suggested by the title
of my book rising powers shrinking
planet to be honest with you it took me
months to come up with that title
because because I'm discussing a very
complicated phenomenon the the new tries
of a new class of powers and actually
there there I described two kinds of
rising powers on one hand the rising
economic dynamos of Asia China and India
Malaysia Thailand South Korea and others
that have vibrant economies that are
growing at a very rapid clip that are
needing large quantities of additional
energy and have strong economy strong
currencies and so are competing with the
United States every day for what remains
of the world's energy and it's partly
through their vigorous competition that
our own economy must compete and our
economy is weakening and the value of
our currency is weakening partly
explains why oil is so expensive each
and every day
that's one class of rising powers but I
also described another class of rising
powers countries like Russia and
Venezuela and Saudi Arabia are part of
that group of energy surplus countries
that are taking advantage of their
surplus to extract wealth from those of
us who are dependent on them for their
energy to extract wealth and also to use
their privileged position to extract
political favors and political
advantages and even military advantage
from the rest of us so there are two
kinds of rising powers so that's half of
my title
the other half shrinking planet
describes the gradual twiddling of
energy supplies and even other kinds of
raw materials minerals in particular
industrial minerals copper cobalt zinc
nickel that the industrial economies of
the world rely on and it's the collision
between these two phenomenon rising
competition for energy and raw materials
and the decline of the world stockpiles
of energy and raw materials that is the
subject of my book and how this plays
out in the global landscape the
geopolitical landscape in Africa in the
Middle East and in Central Asia
so let me speak a little bit more in
detail about these phenomenon the rising
powers shrinking planet landscape that I
believe will dominate world affairs for
as far as we could see into the future
so first the rising powers part let me
say a little bit about that and it seems
odd today to to say this but as recently
as 1990 and 1980s up until 1990 the
world's mature industrial powers that's
the United States Japan Europe and in
those days the former Soviet Union
consumed about three-quarters of the
world's energy supply even though we had
about one-quarter of the world's
population and of course the reverse was
true for the developing world
three-quarters of the world's population
1/4 of the world's energy but that ratio
is changing very dramatically and very
rapidly today the developing world uses
about one-third of the world's energy
and by about 2030 2035 at car
rates of change it'll be 5050 a lot of
this is due to China alone China in 1990
used only about 8% of the world's energy
it's now up to something like 15 percent
of the world's energy and by 2025 China
is expected to use 20% of the world's
energy at which time it's expected to
exceed the United States as the world's
leading energy consumer this will have a
dramatic impact on the competition for
world energy supplies because we now
consume more energy than anybody else we
consume about one-quarter of the world's
energy supply every day American based
energy companies Exxon Mobil and Chevron
and the others have long dominated the
energy global energy equation we now
have to face the prospect of Chinese
based companies CNPC the china national
petroleum corporation sinopec Sinopec
and scenic the china national overseas
onshore oil corporation all competing
vigorously with us for what remains of
energy and China's not alone India is
coming along rapidly and the Malaysian
company Petronas and Brazilian company
Petrobras all of them are working very
vigorously to gain access to overseas
oil supplies and these countries are
developing strategies very effective
strategies to compete with us in most
cases these are state-owned or state
backed companies that are forming
strategic alliances with the national
oil companies of Venezuela Saudi Arabia
Russia the other Middle Eastern and
African countries and those countries
often find it convenient to work with
the national or state backed companies
of China and India they're accustomed to
working that way and they are gradually
edging out the private or what are
called international oil companies like
Chevron BP and shell and ExxonMobil so
we have to expect a world in which we'll
have to we in the mature Western
industrial country is going to have to
work much much harder to gain access to
the kind of energy supplies that we need
that's half of the equation that we face
today this would be the case under any
circumstances we'd face a more intense
competitive environment but that's only
half the story the other half of the
story as just at this time when demand
for energy is soaring because of rising
demand in China and the developing world
the supply of energy is expected to
contract now let me be clear and we can
discuss this at greater length in some
cases this is due to the actual
contraction of energy supplies the
supply of petroleum I believe will rise
for another few years up until about
2012 the actual supply of petroleum may
grow it's now at about 87 million
barrels per day that's how oil is
measured in million barrels per day may
go up to as high as 95 million barrels
per day
I believe that's about as high as it we
could expect it to go and I think around
2012 is the point at which it'll reach a
maximum and then it will decline after
that and maybe by 2025 it'll it'll be
considerably below that level and will
continue to decline natural gas may
continue to grow for another decade
beyond that point coal may be a decade
or so beyond that uranium I'm can't be
really sure but none none
of these traditional sources of energy
will ever grow high enough to support
the level of demand that we could expect
from both the mature industrial
countries the older Western economies
and the soaring demand from China and
India they will always fall short so
even if they grow a bit even if they
grow a bit
they will never rise high enough to me
to anticipate a demand so there will
always be a shortfall it is beginning
now this is the point where that gap
begins and we know that every single day
we drive to a gas station and the rising
prices but we're just at the beginning
that gap will continue to grow and grow
and grow so even if the supply is edging
up a little bit we will experience it as
shortages as scarcity and as I say it
may edge up a little bit oil a little
bit for a few years and then it will
decline natural gas a little longer than
it will decline coal may be a little
longer and then it too will decline so
from now on we have to expect a world in
which energy will appear to be
increasingly scarce now it would be nice
to be able to say to you that we can
anticipate that alternative energies
biofuels renewables wind power solar
power other forms of alternative energy
hydrogen will come along and fill up
that gap each year into the future the
alternatives will be bigger and bigger
and fill up that gap but at current
rates of development I can assure you
that those alternatives if they continue
at current rates of investment will not
fill up that gap they are simply not
being expanded rapidly enough to make up
the difference
so as far as anyone could tell beginning
now and at least till 2050 there will be
a huge scarcity of energy supply now
that's the rising powers shrinking
planet picture assessment that I think
any reasonable person has to draw so the
next question is how are the great
powers responding to this picture well
seems to me that the reasonable response
to that would be to move much more
quickly than we are to developing
alternative energy strategies and to
quickly develop conservation strategies
to require that vehicles be much more
fuel-efficient than they are to adopt
all kinds of energy saving strategies
and that United States take the lead in
energy conservation in energy innovation
and that China our greatest rival in the
search of energy leapfrog from from a
earlier stage of energy development to
the next generation that skip the stage
that we're currently in of what of oil
powered automobiles of coal powered
electricity and jump whole generation to
hybrids and and plug-in hybrids and
electric powered cars and the rest
that's not what's happening the current
leadership of the United States of
America instead of moving in the
direction of rapid development of
alternatives under President Bush has
favoured the perpetuation of the
existing energy paradigm of big oil big
coal nuclear power and natural gas which
entails continued reliance on imported
oil that is the essence of the national
energy policy adopted by President Bush
in 2001
and the Chinese leadership for all their
supposed wisdom has chosen to follow in
our footsteps and to motorize their
population with american-style
automobiles they have made automobiles a
pillar of their industrialization
they're building an interstate highway
system bigger than ours they are
building coal-fired power plants at the
rate of something like one per week
using 1950s era coal technology not the
more advanced coal plants but more
primitive coal plants for the most part
so we have a situation where the two
biggest energy consumers are following a
path of a retrograde path of energy
development the environmental
consequences of this I don't think I
have to tell you are catastrophic and I
can elaborate on that just let me say
that the projections are that by 2030
the US and China alone will be
responsible for half of the world's
carbon dioxide emissions but my greatest
worry and what my book is about is that
the geopolitical implications of this
are that the US and China who together
will be responsible for half the world's
petroleum consumption in 2030 will have
to fight with each other for what
remains of a diminishing pool of world
petroleum supplies and there are only a
few places in the world where they could
go for this diminishing supply of oil
Africa Central Asia the Middle East and
a little bit certain amount in the
Andean region of Latin America
they're only about a dozen countries
left in the world that can supply our
respective needs Azerbaijan and
Kazakhstan and Russia in the former
Soviet Union Iran Iraq Kuwait Saudi
Arabia
United Arab Emirates in the Persian Gulf
region Al Angola Algeria Libya Sudan
Nigeria in Africa Venezuela that's
that's about the list all of these
countries are unstable
many of them are riven by ethnic and
religious disputes many of them are
corrupt or authoritarian what their
leaders want most from their energy
consumers besides money is weapons to
maintain their grip on power and so both
the US and China in their competitive
pursuit of oil are becoming the leading
supplier of arms to many of these
countries often in a competitive fashion
we offer them weapons the Chinese offer
them weapons Russia is also a player in
this not because Russia seeks weapons
I'm sorry not because Russia seeks oil
for its own use but because Russia seeks
to have to grasp a monopoly on the
transportation of energy from the
Caspian Sea area and from the Middle
East through gas prom the world's which
has a monopoly on the transportation of
natural gas from Russia and from the
former Soviet republics so it too uses
arms as an instrument of diplomacy and
political influence so now you have a
cold war like competition with arms as
the as the medium of exchange the
currency in this energy driven
geopolitical competition and I don't
think I have to tell people in the room
just a little bit of history will tell
you that this kind of arms Laden
diplomacy will increase friction and
suspicion and hostility and lead to arms
races and regional conflicts in these
parts of the world that's the least of
the worries
I fear that we have to worry about from
this kind of behavior my big worry in
all of this is that it will lead to
growing suspicion and fear between the
US and China itself and this is not just
my my fantasy my my nightmare vision
just a month ago the US Department of
Defense released its annual report on
the military power of the People's
Republic of China
it's an annual report and this year for
the first time the Department of Defense
identified resource competition between
US and China as as an equal risk with
war over Taiwan as the most likely spark
for a future war between the US and
China it said that in the years ahead as
the struggle over energy and raw
materials becomes more intense and a war
of diminishing resources as China's need
for energy and raw materials becomes
greater competes with the u.s. in these
areas that I described that this
competition will be militarized and
could lead to a conflict with the United
States first time the Department of
Defense said this and this is the
background for a huge increase in
military expenditures this year in China
and the United States a lot of it going
for buildup and naval forces now I
frankly don't think the US and China are
gonna choose to go to war with one
another but I do think you're gonna see
a naval arms race taking place around
protection of sea lanes around
protection of access to foreign oil and
mineral supplies creating a kind of a
cold war environment this is very bad
news
for both of us it's bad news because
it's going to SAP up
unbelievable sums of money overtime in
the trillions of dollars this year's
defense budget US defense budget
includes tens of billions of dollars for
a new class of nuclear-powered aircraft
carriers nuclear-powered submarines a
new class of destroyers and cruisers new
supersonic aircraft that Chinese have
announced a similar build-up not on
quite the scale as our own but
nonetheless huge this is money that will
not be spent will not be available for
the development of energy alternatives
or for addressing global climate change
and will never be available and it's for
that reason that we will not have the
funds we need to address our energy
problems in either country so it seems
to me that we are trapped by this mutual
suspicion this this zero-sum thinking
that we have to compete for energy in a
world of diminishing supplies and my
view and and I'm going to finish with
this thought I end my book with the
argument that we are both victims that
is the US and China are both victims of
this mode of thinking that the solution
to our energy problems is to militarize
the competition between us to view each
other as as implacable competitors in
this struggle for energy and that we
have to use military means as a way of
ensuring that we whoever wit whether
it's us or China that we to preserve our
energy requirements at the expense of
the other that we should we should
prevail at the expense of the other but
through military means that we both will
for as a result we will we will both
both see our societies will decay and
suffer in in is a result because we will
both fall behind in the race to develop
energy alternatives as other societies
that forego this approach and invest in
Safed like many of the European
countries in energy alternatives in post
petroleum energy systems will leap ahead
in the search for new energy systems we
will fall behind and both of our
societies will be losers in this
competition in the end so that we both
therefore have a mutual advantage
instead of competing in this struggle in
cooperating in forming an energy
alliance after all we both remember
we're both going to be the leading the
two leading consumers of energy the
leading two leading emitters of carbon
dioxide the two leading importers of
Patrol importers of petroleum and the
years ahead if we could collaborate in
developing energy alternatives petroleum
post petroleum options we will both be
winners in this new energy new
international energy order that I've
tried to describe to you and so my my
the essence of my argument is that we
will either fall together or we will
survive together in this new system and
to to try to persuade you that this is
not entirely a utopian vision despite
the differences between us there have
been some efforts at cooperation between
the US and China the Department of
Energy has begun a energy research
program
with the equivalent organizations in
China the Secretary of Treasury Henry
Paulson was just in China and met with
his equivalent on the other side and
they've decide they've they set out a
plan for a ten year research program in
energy alternatives and environmental
research so there is the possibility of
collaboration I believe this is the most
urgent task facing the next presidential
administration in the in foreign policy
and energy policy and environmental
policy is to promote cooperation between
the US and China so I'll finish with the
thought again we will either learn to
cooperate in developing energy
alternatives or we're doomed to a
competitive struggle which will result
in the ruination of both of our
societies so I hope we could learn to
cooperate and avoid this dangerous trap
so I'll finish with those words and I
thank you for listening to me and I hope
that this provokes some interesting
thoughts on your part and that you'll
ask me some good questions thank you
very much
[Applause]
yes one two three so how much would you
say that the current price of oil is
affected by the fall of the dollar a
financial speculation of treating
treating oil is a commodity versus peak
oil at this point all of the above
you know the basic the basic fact is the
high price of oil I mean ultimately it's
caused by the fact that the world supply
is not rising as fast as demand that's
the structural background and that will
continue to be true indefinitely in
addition to that there are some day to
day events insurgency fighting in
Nigeria has shut down a certain amount
of production insurgency and pipeline
explosions in Mexico periodically I mean
those are the day-to-day events that
will spark a price rise at any given
moment fear of war with Iran their fear
factor all of these day-to-day events
will affect the price speculation
probably adds some percent five percent
ten percent I can't say but the
structural factor is insufficient demand
to meet rising supply and that's not
going to change oh but you asked about
the the value of the dollar and that's
very important because our currency is
very weak and is declining so if we were
buying we were paying for oil and euros
or yen the rise wouldn't seem as extreme
as it is I'd recognize this person
but in this person and then you'll be
after that yes okay I'm meet the United
States or China is in a vacuum now it's
not like World War two we're
economically dependent on people so it's
not a positive aspect we have to work
with each other already dependent on
each other yes our economies are
dependent but there are but there are
but when it comes to energy
our government has taken a position of
antagonism and I begin my book with the
unical affair of 2005 when China when
Sina the China National Offshore Oil
Company made a legitimate bid for the
unocal corporation you know by the rules
of capitalism they made the higher bid
they should have been able to purchase
that company in Chevron rather than
matching their bid went to Congress and
stirred up anti-china hysteria and
Congress and they would denied the
ability to buy that and the message that
China took from that is that when it
comes to energy that this is not a fair
you know this is not a level playing
field and energy is the most important
commodity in the world today so the
other energy cooperation you're talking
about doesn't prevail economic
cooperation I'm sorry
doesn't prevail when it comes to energy
which is the most important thing yes
please
you mentioned the elections and the
possibility of another Democrats taking
over it seems like energy policy
geostrategy in American history is
pretty much bipartisan and not much
difference between the two
suppose that the Democrats do take over
the White House in Congress what do you
see be what which do you think that
improves the chances very much for
moving in a good direction well I think
that that the Democrats it's you were
right to say not just the White House
but also Congress and we do have
Democrats in the House and the Senate
now but they have not been able to move
energy policy very much because their
margin of advantage is so small
so until the Democrats or like-minded
Republicans because there are some
Republicans who have a very thoughtful
policy on this like Chuck Hagel and a
number of others until there is a big
enough Block in Congress that's willing
to move far more dramatically it doesn't
matter who's in the White House because
this kind of legislation has to have
congressional support so you do need a
president who is going to really rouse
Congress to make dramatic changes and
that's not going to happen overnight
that said I think a president who's
really committed to making change can
make a difference and you know Chuck
Hagel had run for president and I wish
he had I think he could have provided a
lot of leadership on this issue I'm
sorry he hasn't yes ma'am I saw a
documentary in which they were talking
about the strategy of going into Iraq
and that if it was so that in the future
the Iraq area of all the areas where the
oil is is the is going to last the
longest of all the areas they're all
going to dry up quicker than that
so the idea by of our government was to
get in there and dominate it so that the
government there could not in the future
negotiate a pipeline going through the
sea over to China
therefore depriving us of that access in
a kind of war over the oil I got a
negotiated kind of thing you know I mean
so could you talk about that a little
bit please yes I don't share that view
that the war in Iraq was specifically to
get control over Iraq's oil my belief
that is that the war in Iraq was a
consistent with the Carter doctrine of
1980 which says that control of the
entire Persian Gulf and all of its oil
is an American geopolitical
necessity and that any threat to the
control of the Persian Gulf and its oil
and especially the flow of oil through
the Persian Gulf in the Strait of Hormuz
is a threat to America's vital interests
that's what the Carter doctrine of 1980
says and that Saddam Hussein was viewed
as a threat to our vital interests and
this was the cause of the first Persian
Gulf War in 1990 and I believe that's
what President Bush jr. that's the way
he perceived the threat posed by Saddam
Hussein in 2003 that Saddam Hussein had
to be eliminated and I believe that the
current administration views the the
regime in Iran and very much the same
way so I fear that there's a greater
than 50% risk of a attack on the
Iranians before the current
administration leaves office again in
accordance with the Carter doctrine of
2000 I'm sorry of 1980 yes please since
I mean you've made the case pretty
clearly that the American dependence on
imported oil is weakening this country
and has the prospect of doing that for
years to come what do you think are the
chances that enlightened segments of the
ruling class for lack of a better term
will really understand that and turn
America's energy policy around so that
it is not dependent on import
which we are totally capable of doing I
think that there's growing recognition
of that among significant elements of
the American establishment let's call it
that of the political and especially the
corporate and military establishment
there is a whole segment of the military
that is turning away from this reliance
on military force and a corporate a
growing corporate segment that sees the
the lunacy of this policy and you will
find conservative you know traditional
conservative Republicans who are calling
for energy security but through energy
efficiency and energy alternatives one
of the people who wrote an endorsement
from my book is the former commander of
the US Pacific Command and Admiral
Dennis Blair who until recently was one
of the highest-ranking officers in the
US military who has taken the leadership
of this and getting former military
officers very high ranking military
officers to repudiate
this kind of reliance on Persian Gulf
oil and the use of the military for that
purpose
the CEO of FedEx has joined with him in
this effort so I do see signs that a
growing segment of American elites see
the craziness of this kind of policy
others yes United States and China and
I'm wondering what other countries maybe
other energy consumers are going to
influence that relationship for either
better or worse well you know I write
about the triangular relationship
between the US China and Russia as the
three great powers of this new
geopolitical era and one of the reasons
why I think the decision to deny China
to be able to buy unical is because it
pushed China into the arms of Russia and
I think this was a catastrophic
political mistake by the United States
immediately after China was blocked from
Unocal who Jintao the president of China
went to Moscow and signed a strategic
alliance of some kind with Vladimir
Putin or just about the same time in
which they signed a document announcing
America's you know unilateral you
unilateralism or hegemon ISM is the term
that they use and call for closer
military ties and shortly after that
there was a summit meeting of the
Shanghai Cooperation Organization the
SEO which is this you Chinese Russian
military security organization in
Central Asia which called for the u.s.
to abandon its bases in Central Asia and
they have beefed up the SCO as a vehicle
for pushing the u.s. out and I feel that
China left to its own own best interests
would would seek to avoid an embrace of
Vladimir Putin but we are pushing them
in that direction
so I really think it's a it we've made a
strategic blunder by giving China the
message that we're not going to
cooperate with them yes oh you didn't
ask a question please you know we talked
about China and that what what are the
implications for the situation in Mexico
I mean for us it's it's right against
our borders it'll be immediate and it
with the decline of production in Mexico
with kind of political ramifications
there may be military ramifications do
we have if their economy you know 40
percent of their tax revenue come
from Pemex is that unravels over the
next couple of years you know we're we
looking at military action there did we
bring our military into play I me what
are your take on it that's a very
interesting question I mean I just think
that that leads to the further
militarization of the US Mexican border
because an unraveling in Mexico you know
obviously will lead to greater migratory
precious into the United States and and
we can be assume that that will lead to
greater resistance to that and higher
walls and you know more vigilantes on
the border but I can't think beyond that
it's certainly the consequences of that
will be severe for the United States
because we now import oil from Mexico
and that's coming to an end very soon
Mexico will compete with us for imported
oil
so that'll push the price up and make
things harder for us I don't I don't
know what other implications that might
have it might I mean I don't know how
long ago Chavez will be in business
right but it could strengthen his
efforts to create a Latin American
energy block that has anti-american
overtones because Pemex might turn to
Venezuela for supplies and cooperation
conceivably with a rape more radical
Mexican president and that would be very
very dramatic in its implications I
hadn't thought about that but you put
that in my mind you've got you know now
it attacks the tax implication is there
but you have that whole constitutional
problem with Pemex essentially being
constitutionally locked out of foreign
oil companies coming in even adding
expertise or talent to this and so it it
seems to me that there we have a attend
a pending disaster just south of our own
borders let alone the Middle East but we
may have a political geopolitical
collapse potentially and that that's
that's kind of where I was asking yes
well I'll have to give further thought
to that I I hadn't thought of it in
those political terms
yes please and then you and then you in
general are the the oil-producing
countries gaining leverage in the
context of the situation that you
described or is it really a factor of
individuals situations and circumstances
based on their own political factors are
they playing this situation to their
advantage or are they really simply at a
disadvantage given the strong force that
the United States and China can apply to
their situation well it very it it
varies of course but there certainly
gain first of all they're gaining wealth
in 2006 the oil exporting countries
gained a trillion dollars and I'm sure
that the number when it's calculated for
2007 will be approximately double that
and they're investing that money where
they're there they're collecting that
money in what I call sovereign wealth
funds among other things and they're
using that to buy up strategic sectors
of the American economy like Citibank
and the Carlyle Group and key
corporations now they saying we're not
you know we're not going to involve
ourselves politically we're not gonna
use this for political purposes but it's
hard for me to believe that once they
gain control of these critical sectors
of the American economy that these
sovereign wealth funds like the Kuwaiti
Investment Authority in the Abu Dhabi
Investment Authority won't at some point
attempt to use that for political
leverage I just find that very hard to
believe they also use this for political
leverage of various kinds
Sudan the Sudanese government obviously
has put pressure on China to back them
at UN Security Council to prevent the
Security Council from imposing sanctions
of various kinds on Sudan
I I believe that the fact that President
Bush goes around talking about you know
democracy in the Middle East but never
talks about Saudi Arabia and so that you
know and talking about bringing rights
to women but never in Saudi Arabia which
has the most repressive conditions for
women anywhere in the world practically
except you know toilet the Afghanistan
under the Taliban is because of
deference to the Saudi royal family I
mean maybe that's not that's deference
so of course they have influence over us
you know President Bush went there in
January and he pleaded with the Saudi
royal family to produce more oil to
lower the price of gasoline and he was
basically told to get lost as if you
know he was representing some distant
satrapy you know go away you that's
that's the kind of relationship we have
with them now so the more the the more
we're dependent the the more power and
influence
they'll have and the less we'll have I
think that's that's the nature of the
relationship that's developing I had
recognized somebody else and but I know
you're yes it was you and then and that
you know that it's it's it's a well
that's gonna be a that's a pretty
limiting factor in mining for energy I
mean like like the coal the oil shales
up in Calgary yes you can I mean they
take a lot makes a lot of water yes and
then also like that for agriculture too
but what do you think what do you see in
the future for for ending this craze of
biofuels like between the Brazil's or
Brazil's producing and like the u.s. - I
mean do you see it that's going to come
to an end I mean you're this you know
this ethanol stuff and everything else I
mean we're we're we're planning you know
corn for ethanol
but I mean supplement or for my from
what I understand you know we're facing
a giant global food crisis and food is
just water in another form it takes a
thousand pounds of water to produce one
pound of grain and the more scarcity of
water the less food there's going to be
so all of these issues are
interconnected and the more water and
land is devoted to producing ethanol
through conventional means the less food
there's going to be available the more
instability and chaos you're going to
have in developing countries and you
asked about Mexico Mexico could be the
next country to blow up because of
rising food prices and that will lead to
chaos much sooner than than anything
else so the issue of ethanol is very
explosive now there are technologies
underway to produce ethanol in using
chemical means so-called say los
cellulosic ethanol and even more
advanced measures using algae and other
other technologies that that I propose
be advanced much more rapidly than they
are but that's going to take a lot of
investment money we're not putting the
kind of money into that that's necessary
but the current make way of making
ethanol is a catastrophe and has to be
abandoned I believe
production well if you mean that if we
if we stop producing ethanol and it's
not so much the ethanol in this country
that's no take that back I'm not sure I
understand the nature of your question I
guess it seems to me that if we just
really got down to conserving or
whatever the government got behind a
conservation program that we could we
wouldn't have to produce something but
we wouldn't have to produce ethanol or
the amount of ethanol we're producing
you know right now I mean using by
agriculture is just kind of yeah well
the the motive for producing ethanol is
partly to reduce our dependence on
imported oil and that we could do
through conservation the there's another
motive is that if we could produce
ethanol without the in a different
manner without using energy without
using fossil fuels to produce it you
also reduce the level of carbon dioxide
emissions and that's a worthy goal but
we have to do it in a different fashion
than we are yes please well start with
the first part so I see if I could
answer that okay the amount of solar
energy that's incident on the earth just
in a very small percentage of their
Earth's surface is enough to meet all of
our energy needs some of it is collected
by algae and seaweed yeah there are ways
of mining it there's also been a lot of
development of these so-called amorphous
semiconductors which are very efficient
solar collectors to spread on deserts
and so forth collect so why isn't those
energies which the investment would not
be enormous is already pretty far along
why precisely is that not being pursued
so that the interest of the oil
companies that are other interests why
isn't that being but there the problem
with solar is for one thing is it my
understanding is not the problem with
solar we can we could overcome the
problem with collecting solar energy the
problem is delivering solar energy to
the place where it's needed
I live in New England
and solar collectors there are not very
practical for most of the year the
problem is that where where it's
efficient is in the American Southwest
but the transmission lines for
delivering it are not very efficient so
much more research has to go into
improving the efficiency of transmission
lines and this is something again where
I think we need much more government
funded investment in entrepreneurial
research and it's just not being done so
well every day that goes by we have more
labor reducing labor eliminating
Technology robotics computers
biotechnology
how will capitalism can capitalism
survive past that when you have to get
rid of your workforce and replace them
with computers robots and biotechnology
I'm afraid I don't know the answer to
that but I'll think about it
thank you for stimulating my thinking
yes please the Rio treaty and poetry
neither one of them were very demanding
as far as conservation or reducing
emissions was concerned now that Kyoto
is coming to an end in the context of
this new geopolitics do you have an idea
what is likely to happen or what people
ought to be trying to accomplish you
know my my worry is that the US and
China are simply gonna not agree to a
regime that will address the issues that
I discussed in my talk they will pay
lip-service to some kind of agreement
that might sound like they're they're
agreeing to make progress but they're
not going to address the core problems
for example coal use
and increased automobile use that's the
heart of the problem and I don't believe
either the US or China are going to make
the kind of binding necessary steps that
will lead to diminished carbon dioxide
emissions that's going to have to come
from binding legislation in China and
the United States and by the way China
and the United States both have the same
problem that you may have statements
made by leaders the the Chinese
leadership may make a statement in fact
they have the president of China and the
Prime Minister have made reasonably
decent statements about the need to
reduce China's energy footprints and
carbon dioxide emissions but they have
failed to implement those to create the
machinery and the mechanisms to
implement them at the provincial and the
county level and the system is so
corrupt and and so entrenched with local
power interests and corporate interests
that the system is breaking down and we
have similar problems in our own country
with lobbyists and others that undermine
whatever speeches President Bush has so
we need a clean political sweep in both
countries to see that happen difficult
you can't get can't make money out of
getting rid of car co2 I think it's
possible to do that I think it is but I
mean up there
[Music]
if I think if the reward structure is
put in place in terms of Taxation and
tax benefits it can be done maybe the
last question please yeah I was just uh
you talked about the polls as you saw
them for invading Iraq I was just
wondering if you could talk a little bit
about what you thought the future of the
insurgency there would be and how that
would affect those goals the insurgency
is really a oil resource conflict as far
as I'm concerned and it's it's not an
insurgency there I mean there's an
insurgency there is an oil warlordism
struggle in the in Basra and there is a
oil separatist conflict in the north so
there are three separate oil related
struggles going on to to put this in
context Iraq as a manufactured creation
it was created by the British Empire
after World War one for the purpose of
extracting Iraq's oil and it was
clobbered together covered together from
three provinces of the Ottoman Empire
Mosul in the north which is primary
mostly Kurdish the Sunni areas in
Baghdad and the Shiite areas around
Basra the Kurdish area one areas want to
break away and create an oil fueled oil
financed state in the north and they
don't want to give any money to the
central government in Baghdad the Shiite
area in the areas in the south want to
create a kingdom or a Shiite state I
should say financed by oil revenues and
give none of the money to Baghdad except
that they are divided between different
Shiite militias that are fighting
amongst themselves for who's going to
control that oil wealth that's what the
fighting in Basra was about a few weeks
ago between competing Shiite war law
essentially and the Sunnis in the middle
see a picture in which there'll be two
separate oil parent parents in which
they'll get nothing so they're fighting
an insurgency to prevent that from
happening that's my interpretation of
what's going on and American troops are
caught in the middle and we're seeing
deaths every day as a consequence of our
failure to anticipate that this is what
would happen and I don't see that
there's any plan on anybody's part to
solve this remember the surge was
predicated on the basis that we would
give breathing room for Iraqi officials
to solve this one problem this is what
the surge was for to get the Iraqi
officials to solve this to work out an
oil law that would distribute the oil
revenues it has been an utter failure it
is going in the opposite direction so
far as I could tell so I see no prospect
that there will ever be a solution to
this they'll just be continued fighting
but thank you for asking that I think
every American has to understand this
thank you
[Applause]